LEBRON AND CP3, YES?
OKAY, GOOD.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
WE GOT OUR ASS KICKED.
IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE.
THEY DID WHATEVER THEY DID TO
GET IN THIS GAME AND WE'VE GOT
TO BE THE OPPOSITE IF WE WANT TO
FORCE A GAME SEVEN.
OBVIOUSLY A LOT TO LEARN FROM IN
THIS GAME, A LOT TO COVER, SEE
WHAT WE GOT TO DO BETTER GOING
TO GAME SIX.
BUT THEY PRETTY MUCH JUST KICKED
OUR ASS.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE REALLY TO
SAY.
>> I'VE BEEN TALKING TO KYLE
LOWERY.
HE HAD A SIMILAR INJURY LAST
YEAR.
THE OTHER GUYS, JUST A VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE FEELING, KIND OF
HELPLESS.
WHEN IT HAPPENED I DIDN'T KNOW.
I WAS JUST LOOKING UP AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT AFTER I SEEN HIM I CAME OUT
AND TOLD WEST IT WAS